-New White House Press Secretary
Kayleigh McEnany
has been holding a lot
of press briefings lately,
but she seems to avoid
answering the questions
we need answered most,
so we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right, Kayleigh McEnany
is here and ready to go,
so, without further ado,
it's time
for the Late Night
White House Press Briefing.
♪♪
Yes! Yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary McEnany,
do you have any update
on the number
of new COVID cases today?
-They went like this, and that's
thanks to President Trump.
-And, yes,
where's the safest place
for Americans to be, right now,
to avoid catching
the coronavirus?
-The rest of the world.
-What would you say has been
Trump's biggest nemesis, so far,
when it comes to his
response to the pandemic?
-Reality.
-What were the results
of President Trump's
last physical?
-We have beef operating
at 98% capacity,
pork at 95%,
and poultry at 98%.
-June was Pride Month.
Does President Trump even know
which people it celebrates?
-FQHCs.
-Oh! Almost. LGBTQs.
We were looking for LGBTQs.
When you interviewed
for the job,
what kind of questions
did they ask you?
-Not one question.
I didn't receive one question.
-If President Trump
hadn't cheated on his SATs,
what school could he
have gotten into?
-Let's say
University of Phoenix.
-How many French fries
does the president eat?
-About 500,000 per day.
-Now that a Trump appointee
is running the U.S. post office,
what will their new slogan be?
-I can't promise you
it's tomorrow,
but, in the coming days,
we look to deliver that.
-Kayleigh,
how does Mitch McConnell
keep his neck skin
under control?
-Incredibly strong ties.
-Where will President Trump
have his eventual,
complete nervous breakdown?
-On Twitter, for all to see.
-Why are there so many people
with Confederate flags
at Trump rallies?
-We hand them out.
-What does Trump say
when he goes to a Denny's
and there's a maze
on the back of a place mat?
-Where do you draw
the line here?
-Melania Trump
was raised Catholic.
Why did Trump decide not
to join the Catholic Church
when they got married?
-He's not a fan of the kneeling.
-Is there a mnemonic
device you use
to remember Trump's lunch order
of a cheeseburger,
Ho Hos, Oreos, and a Pepsi?
-CHOP, C-H-O-P.
-I heard President Trump
is writing a parenting book.
What's it called?
-The negative impacts
of children.
-What does it mean when the
manager walks out to the mound,
looks to the bullpen,
and taps his left arm like this?
-Bring in Cy Vance, a Democrat.
-What is Jared Kushner's role
in this administration?
-Important tool.
-What was Rosebud,
from the movie "Citizen Kane"?
-It's a comment
that he made in passing.
-[ Laughing ]
I see what you did
there, Kayleigh.
What does Trump call using
the McDonald's drive-through?
-People attending church
in their cars?
-What happens when Donald Trump
comes up to a door
labeled "Pull"?
-The president,
he's going to push.
-Tell me a scary story
about Trump being president.
-He wants to do it again.
-Aah!
When was Major League Baseball
the most fun to watch?
-When steroids were used.
Is it true
that President Trump thinks
he's a better saxophone-playing
president than Bill Clinton?
-He believes it'd go a long way
if Bubba came out
and acknowledged that.
-What did President Trump say
when Kentucky Fried Chicken
changed its name to KFC?
-We've gotta honor
what has happened there,
not rename it.
-Alright, Kayleigh, be honest.
What would you guess my role was
on the high school
football team?
-Absolute nonstarter.
-Anh, you're not wrong.
Well, you're a little wrong.
I wasn't even on the team.
If Trump gets reelected,
do you think we'll see
all Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse appear?
-There will be, I think, five.
-Five? Oh.
That'll be somethin'.
What should I make,
in order to make sure
I get a table at a restaurant
that allows indoor dining,
doesn't require
social distancing,
and doesn't require masks?
-They're grave reservations.
-Grave, grave reservations.
Did you guys hear that?
Oh, I'm the only?
I'm the only one here?
Looks like we have time
for one more question,
so I'll make it
an important one.
If you could watch any two
people from history bone,
Who would you choose?
-Susan B. Anthony
and Billy Graham.
-Wow! Alright.
Thank you for your
honesty, Kayleigh.
And it looks like we're
out of time, so, on behalf
of the rest the Late Night
Press Corps, have a good night.